[Musique]
sous les lueurs pourpre d'un ciel
primitif le misérable sorcier plongée
enfin son bras tout au fond de la
fissure
[Musique]
100 points se referma sur l'oeil du
serpent
[Musique]
et éternelle j'aimerais lui tu as il me
chercher cette fille que j'ai vu tu sais
ce que tu dois faire
tu es une femme spéciale mandy moi aussi
je suis un être spécial
joins toi moi nous sommes faits pour
être spéciaux ensemble
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire avec ça
je passais ce tube heures chasse est
quoi
te ferais t'aimerons
vous croyez tellement 1re
je vais te montrer ce que c'est l'amour
des tons fait du tort
tu transpires une noirceur cosmique
objet s'illumine un de l'intérieur
étrange et éternelle
à